we are two days away from the election
republicans and democrats are rallying
to secure votes for their candidates in
nevada
orco mana attended a rally for president
donald trump this afternoon
near the strip but first kristen
drummond joins us in the newsroom with
more on how the state democratic party
is
mobilizing voters kristin sasha the
state democratic party is hosting a
series of events the next couple of days
all encouraging people to vote now this
final push aims to make sure
everyone can cast a ballot to help
decide this election
i'm seeing what makes the state great
words of encouragement
thank you everybody that's volunteering
governor steve sislak helps launch a
nevada democratic party canvassing event
at bruce trent park
we're trying to rally up grassroots
workers he joins congresswoman susie lee
nevada senate majority leader nicole
cannazzero and nevada assemblywoman
shea backus all here to thank roughly
150 volunteers
choosing to knock on doors and encourage
people to vote
we all have to pitch in we all have to
do our part aurelie allercon cast her
ballot for the first time this election
a little overwhelming and a lot of
anxiety around it the 19 year old
attends unlv
and is president of dems on campus she
came to support the democratic
candidates and mobilized voters before
tuesday
we're going to lip drop some communities
and some houses and hopefully get
people the resources they need to know
how to vote on election day
since early voting has ended and just to
help them make their voting plan
that's what elections are about they're
about knocking doors and getting people
out to vote a challenge
these volunteers accept i'll be out the
next two days
from sun up to sun down to make sure
everyone who can
does make their voice heard on election
day i just don't want to wake up on
november 4th
and think that i could have done more
plans to host a few more canvassing
events tomorrow as well as tuesday